الان نتابع معك ومع كذلك مشاهدينا ايضا
على الشاشه صور الاستقبالات ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
لرؤساء الوفود العربيه المشاركه في اعمال
هذه القمه قمه جدا العربيه الثانيه
والثلاثه بعد ان اكتمل وصول القاده
والزعماء والامراء وكذلك رؤوس الوقود
المشاركه في اعمال هذه القمه نشاهد الان
الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني مثل دوله قطر
الذي يستقبل الامير محمد بن سلمان الان في
مقر انعقاد هذه القمه في جده
وحديث جانبي كذلك ودي بين الامير محمد بن
سلمان حمدان
القطري الذي يشارك في اعمال القمه قمه جده
الثانيه والثلاثين
يتوافد ايضا او يستمر توافذ قاده الدول
والوفود ايضا المشاركه في اعمال هذه القمه
والكثير من الملفات مطروحه على جدول اعمال
الرؤسسه والزعماء ايضا وقاده الوفود وهي
ملفات تشكل تحديات كبيره ربما
القاده في مناقشاتهم وفي طريقه كذلك
التعاطيل مع
الملفات ايضا هذا رئيس الوفد السوداني
ايضا
الوفد السوداني والملف السوداني واحد من
اهم الملفات
التي ستطرح او المطروحه على جدول اعمال
هذه القمه هناك تطلعات وامال كذلك بالوصول
الى حلول او طريقه ربما او قط الطريق لوضع
حلول لمعالجه الازمه السودانيه السودانيه
كانت السعوديه قد اعلنت عن اتفاق جده بين
طرفي الصراع الذي
ركز كثيرا على الجوانب الانسانيه لمعالجه
الازمه الانسانيه التي انتجتها هذا الصراع
الدائر في السودان اليوم
وكان ايضا لها دور كبير ايضا من خلال
عمليات اجلاء كبيره قامت بها من اساطيل
سمنه تتواجدت في ميناء فورد سودان لاجلاء
الكثير من رعايه الدول
المتضرره
كانوا متواجدين على ساحه هذه المعارك
كرئيس رئيس البرلمان اللبناني نجيب ميقاتي
ايضا رئيس الوفد اللبناني يشارك في هذه
القمه لب ذلك احداها يعني الملفات المهمه
التي تناقش على مستوى هذه القمه كانت مسار
الحديث والنقاش في اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه
العرب
وكذلك سيكون ملف اللبناني حاضرا ايضا في
جدول اعمال هذه القمه واثناء النقاشات
الرؤساء والزعماء والقاده نفود المشاركين
في اعمالها لبنان تعيش حاله
صعبه من
الاقتصاد اللبناني الان الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس ابو مازن يصل الى مقر انعقاد
القمه والملف الفلسطيني ملف ثابت والملف
ربما الاول على جدول اعمال القمه منذ بدء
اعمالها وحتى اليوم الكثير من التطورات في
الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي ربما كان
اخرها ما حدث يعني قبل ايام
في المواجهات التي تمت في غزه وكذلك في
بعض المناطق في الضفه الغربيه وواحد
الملفات كذلك
المؤرق
للشعب العربيه وكذلك يعني للزعماء اثناء
كل مناقشاتهم الان
يستقبل الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ولي العهد السعودي رئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس ابو مازن الذي يراس الوفد
الفلسطيني المشارك في اعمال هذه القمه
دكتور سميح الملف الفلسطيني هو الملف
الاول دائما على جدول الاعمال القمم
العربيه جميعا الى اي مدى يمكن ان تتحرك
الى القمه جده في التعامل مع هذا الملف
تبعا لتطورات الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
بعتقد اللي راح يخرج من القمه هو لغه
خلينا نقول لغه قويه بالادانه تجاه
اسرائيل تجاه لانه الفتره الاخيره كان في
يعني عدوان على غزه وكان في بالضفه
الغربيه وموضوع الاستفزازات بالقدس فراح
تكون لغه البيان قويه تجاه الاسرائيليه
لسبب ايضا وفي دعوه لحل الدولتين طبعا
وعمليه سلام لكن الكل بيعرف هو حتى
الاطراف المعنيه فيها انه الاسرائيليين
بتعاملوا بسلبيه جدا مع عمليه السلام يعني
ليس في اجنده الاسرائيليين الذهاب الى اي
عمليه سلام او تفاوض مع الفلسطينيين
وبالتالي بعتقد انه
سيكون الخطاب او ما يتعلق البند الخاص
بفلسطين في ادانا اكبر في نوع من الشجر
باكبر في نوع من الرفض للسياسه
الاسرائيليه والاجراءات الاسرائيليه
وتاكيد على هذا الموضوع
بشكل كبير
زائد التاكيد على موضوع الحل السياسي
والتفاوض وحل الدولتين بهذا الموضوع جيد
الرئيس ايضا التونسي قيس سعيد
يستقبل من قبل ولي العهد السعودي في مقر
عقاد القمه في جده تونس كذلك استمر بمرحله
صعبه الدكتور سميح على صيد السياسي وعلى
الصعيد الاقتصادي وغيرها هو بالتالي
السؤال المطروح ماذا يمكن ان نقدم الزعماء
في مناقشاته للتعامل مع هذا الملف الملف
التونسي يعني ما في ملف كان متضرر الاول
من حاله الربيع يعتبر اكثر منه
ملف مع القوى السياسيه التونسيه
ملف مع الانتخابات كده اعتقد انه لا تعتبر
ازمه من الازمات وتعتبر انه وحده من
المشكلات الداخليه لتونس وبالتالي هو ليس
من الملفات الضاغطه والمهمه جدا على
الاجنده القمه وليس ازمه زي السودان او زي
القضيه الفلسطينيه او زي اليمن وبالتالي
هذا الموضوع بكل ما يتم الحديث في تونس
اذا تم الحديث في سيكون بشكل عام لكن
تونس يعني هي الدوله وتسير والقصص اللي
موجوده او القضايا الموجوده هي قضايا
بالعلاقات الثنائيه بين الدوله التونسيه
واحزاب وقوه سياسيه وتحديدا ما يتعلق
بالاسلاميين وما يتعلق بقضايا الارهاب
والتطرف اللي موجوده ايضا من مجموعات اخرى
تقوم بعمليه
ارابيه بتونس زائد الملف السياسي بين حركه
النهضه وبين الحكومه التونسيه لكن ليست
تونس لا تصنف انها ازمه من ازمات
القمه او ملف من ملفات القمه الضاغطه كنا
شاهدنا رئيس الوفد المغربي كذلك صاحب
السمو الملكي الامير رشيد بن الحسن الثاني
رئيس لفت المغربي المشارك في اعمال القمه
العربيه الثانيه 32 في جده
ويستمر ايضا وصول رؤساء وقاده الوفود
المشاركين في اعمال القمه العربيه الثانيه
والثلاثين
نتابع معكم الان كذلك
المشهد الان مقر انعقاد القمه واستقبالات
ولي العهد السعودي ايضا
لرؤساء الوفود المشاركين
لان يبدو اننا نشاهد الان الرئيس محمد
يونس النفي رئيس المجلس الرئاسي الليبي
الذي يراس الوقت اللي بالمشارك في اعمال
هذه القمه الان الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي يصل الى مقر العقاد القمه العربيه
الثانيه والثلاثين في طريقه ايضا لمقابله
مصافحه الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد
السعودي هذا هو السيد محمد النفي رئيس
المجلس الرئاسي الليبي شاهدوا الان على
الصوره المباشر
وكذلك الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
الملف الليبي دكتور سميح الملفات
يستعصي على الذهاب الى خطوه عمليه
انتخابات في ليبيا جوزيان الهدف الذي يجري
الحديث عنه واليوم في تفاؤل من صالح عقيله
رئيس النواب في ليبيا يتحدث انه احتمال ان
تكون الانتخابات قبل نهايه العام لكن
المؤشرات يعني هذا التفاؤل يحتاج الى دعم
بمعطيات اخرى ليبيا يعني هذا الانقسام
اللي فيها تصدي الجغرافي خليني اقول وجود
اكثر من سلطه في ليبيا بعتقد ملف اصبح
طويل الامد
الملف الاقتصادي ايضا من المسائل الصعبه
على حدود مصر ليبيا على حدود مصر مصر غزه
على حدود مصر على مصر من الدول اللي
بتتاثر بما يجري في غزه بتتاثر بما يجري
في ليبيا وتاثر باجري في السودان يعني
امنيا واقتصاديا الان كذلك نتابع ايضا
رئيس مجلس القياده الرئيسي اليمني الدكتور
رشاد محمد العليمي ليستقبله ولي العهد
السعودي
الان رئيس الوفد اليمني المشارك في اعمال
هذه القمه بالمناسبه لن ينضم الينا كذلك
هاتفيا احمد الصالح مستشار رئيس مجلس
القياده الرئاسيه اليماني سيد احمد اهلا
وسهلا بك معنا في تغطيتنا عبر شاشه
العربيه لاعمل القمه الثانيه والثلاثين في
في جده الان يصل الرئيس اليمني والملف
اليمني ايضا واحد من اهم الملفات المطروحه
على الطاوله تعمل القاده كذلك في مناقشه
ماذا يمكن ان تقدم جده او ما المطلوب الان
تقديمه
بعد التطورات الاخيره الحاصله في الملف
اليمني مساله الاتفاق في السعوديه
الايراني وانعكاسات ذلك على ايضا
الازمه في اليمن
على ساده المشاهدين في الحقيقه انه طبيعه
الحال ما يمكن تقديمها في هذه القمه
السابقه والبيانات السابقه تكافه يعني
اجراءات الحكوميه العربيه اللي حصل على
دعم الحكومه الشرعيه مثلا مجلس الشهداء
الرئاسي
وكذلك ايضا سترون هناك احاطه للرئيس مجلس
القياده الرئاسي في هذه المساله ماذا قدمت
الحكومه وما هي التنازلات التي حاولت
تقديمها اتباعا برعايه وجهد الاشقاء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وسلطنه عمان
والمجتمع الدولي ايضا والامم المتحده في
سبيل يعني انجاح اي نوع من انواع
المشاورات او المفاوضات التي تفضي الى
الحقيقه اننا نتطلع في هذه القمه الى دعم
الحكومه مثلا مجال الرئاسي دعم الاقتصادي
الدعم العسكري الدعم السياسي تنفيذ الدعم
السياسي الذي هو لا القائم في هذه اللحظه
ما في شك ان هذه القمه يعني في الحقيقه هي
مليئه ملفات كثيره جدا لكن تعرف يعني ملف
اليمني يخص يعني المجتمع العربي بشكل كبير
جدا
وخصوصا الدوله التي تستضيف كمال المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والدول المنطقه عموما
وبالتالي نحن تطلعاتنا يعني كبيره جدا في
مساله اعاده التاكيد على دعم الحكومه
الشرعيه وفي نفس الوقت يعني وجود اليه
حقيقيه للدعم الاقتصادي خصوصا في هذا
الظروف التي اشرت يعني كثيرا على المواطن
اليمني في الداخل وبالتالي عملنا كبير جدا
في ان تكون هناك يعني برنامج
اذا تسمحلي بس فقط في المقاطعه الان الى
وصول ايضا جهه الملك حمد بن عيسى الخليفه
ملك مملكه البحرين رئيس لفت البحريني
اشارك في اعمال الدوره العاديه 32
الاجتماع مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه على
مستوى القمه
وايضا استكمال ولي العهد له
والتقاط ربما الصور التذكاريه بعد قليل ثم
البدء في اعمال هذه القمه اعود اليك سيد
احمد تفضل وعذرا
فما كنت
اقوله القمه
الكبيره طلع على البيئه الاسلامي وهو اكد
ما ما ذكرته سلفا لكن ما نؤكد عليهم ما
نطلبه في هذا الظروف الموجوده بانه الدوله
قد
وحاولت شاهد استيعاب كافه يعني متطلبات
الاستلام لكن للاسف الشديد من الحوثيين
تعنته تعنت كبير جدا واصروا على مساله
تمردهم انقلابهم على الدوله وحتى رفضوا
كافه المبادرات الاقليميه التي قادتها
المملكه في رمضان وسلطنه عمان وحتى
المبعوث الامريكي اول الاممي وبالتالي نحن
فقط ما نتطلبه في هذه القمه بحكم انها
ايضا فيها زخم كبير جدا لملفات كبيره
وشائكه خصوصا التي ملفات مستجده مثل الملف
السوداني وكذلك تعقيدات الملف اللبناني
والملف الليبي وغير الملفات نعمل فقط على
اعاده تاكيد على اعاده الدعم الشرعيه
اليمنيه مثلا مجلس الرئاسي وكذلك
الدعم الاقتصادي وهو امر الحقيقه يعني يمس
حياه الناس ويمس ايضا منظومه الدوله
وكانها القانوني
طب هل لديكم اي معلوماتي الى اين يمكن ان
تصل قمه جده في تعطيها اليوم مع الملف
اليمني والتطورات
التي كانت تبعا لوزراء الخارجيه العرب وما
تم صياغه الختاميه ربما يلبي جزء
الجانب لكن سنواصل جهودنا كدوله ومنظومه
حكوميه في المتابعه ويعني متابعه مستجدات
ومتابعه ما يمكن عمله
الرئيس محمد شياع السوداني رئيس مجلس
الوزراء العراقي يصل الان وهو رئيس الوفد
المشارك في اعمال الدوره العاديه الثانيه
والثلاثين اجتماع مجلس جامعه الدول
العربيه على مستوى اتفضل سيد احمد
وايضا بالتاكيد على تنفيذ الالتزامات
السابقه سواء مؤتمر المانحي الذي شارك من
الدول العربيه الموجوده اليوم او من الدول
التي دخلت معنا في تحالفات خصوصا في في
دول العصر في الحزم هناك التزامات كبيره
جدا وهناك ايضا الذين فجوها ماليه كبيره
جدا في دعم الحكومه وبالتالي
كل حرص على اعاده جدول هذه الالتزامات
وصياغتها وعليه تنفيذها في الحقيقه نظرا
للصعوبات الكبيره التي تواجه مجلس القاده
الرئاسي والحكومه كلنا عمل الحقيقه في
اشكال العرب الذين لديهم امكانيات تماما
اهميه الالتزامات كثيره حاليا فيها ظروف
الموجوده لكن هذا يعني في الحقيقه لا
يجعلنا ابدا عن
نسخه احلامنا وامالنا في اشقائنا واخواننا
وقفوا معنا في احلى الظروف الفترات
السابقه بان يعني لا يقوم بالتزاماتهم كما
وعدونا في لزامات سابقه اعتقد ان اليوم في
امس الحاجه الى
القيامات والافاده بها في الحقيقه خصوصا
في الجانب الاقتصادي والتاكيد على الدعم
في الجانب السياسي وهذا امر مهم جدا
بالحقيقه الظروف
شكرا جزيلا لك احمد الصالح المستشار رئيس
مجلس القياده
الرئاسي اليمني
الشيخ مشعل احمد الجابر الصباح ولي عهد
دوله الكويت ايضا المشارك في اعمال القمه
يصل الى مقر انعقاد قمه جدا دكتور الملفات
كثيره يعني ونحن نتابع استقبالات يعني
يرتبط كل ضيف بملف العراق قبل قليل كان
السيد احمد شياع السوداني قد وصل العراق
ايضا واحد من الملفات ايضا التي تناولتها
كل القمم تقريبا السابقه يعني او اغلبها
فبالتالي الى اي مدى يمكن ان تقدم الان
قمه جد حلولا لمعالجه الازمه في العراق
مع القمه باعتبارها معجزه يعني هذه عمل
سياسي لقاء عربي بناقش بيقدم ما يستطيع
بتوافق على بعض الملفات بتعامل معها
بطريقه ما لكن احنا مش امام سحريه مجرد ان
تبدا ستنتهي المشكله والا كان ازماتنا
اللي من الاربعينات كانت وقفت وكانت
تعالجت بطريقه اخرى لكن بضل وجود قمه
عربيه بضل حاله عربيه توافقيه القاده
بيلتقوا بيتعاملوا معهد القضايا لو احيانا
بكون في يعني تاثير ايجابي على بعض
الملفات واحيانا الملفات يعني مثلا زي
القضيه الفلسطينيه بالتاكيد هذه قضيه حجم
تعقيده حجم ارتباطاتها الدوليه حجم تاثير
اسرائيل
الامريكان فيها حجم الانقسام الفلسطيني
تداعيات خطيره اكبر او كبيره اكبر من
القمه اليوم الملف اليمني قديش عمره رغم
لكن المره هذه مثلا اليمن الامر مختلف بعد
التفاهم الايراني السعودي وبعد ما جرى
موضوع الهدنه اللي تم الاخرين في خطوات
ايجابيه لقدام يمكن البناء عليه نوع من
التفاؤل سوريا ممكن نعطي دوم التفاؤل
لقدام في شيء ممكن يتم بعيد المدى او يمكن
اقرب من ذلك بنحكي عن ملفات العراق على
سبيل المثال اللي لما كانت تتناقش قضيه
العراق ب 2010 ولا ب 2009 ولا 2008 غير
العراق لما بتتناقش اليوم العراق لمكان
فيها مثلا داعش بال 2014 بالموصل غير
العراقي اليوم ملف العراقي اليوم العراق
ملفات وايضا متعلقه بالاقتصاد متعلقه
بالمياه متعلقه بعلاقته بتركيا مشكلاته مع
يعني في كل بلد عندهم مشكلات داخليه ويطلب
الدعم العربي الها في بعض القضايا بعتقد
انه في بعض الامور خطونا خطوات يعني احنا
لو بنغمض عيوننا بنرجع مثلا خمس سنوات ست
سنوات عشره في الملف العراق كانوا العرب
بعيدين عن العراق في هذا الامر اليوم
العرب قريبين من العراق اليوم في تقارب
عربي مع العراق في اكثر كان في قناع عند
بعض الدول العربيه المهمه انه نحن مدام
الايرانيين الموجودين بالعراق ما دام لهم
قوه وسياسيه ما راح نوقف ونخدمه وكذا زي
هيك بعدين اقتنعوا انه لا ما بنترك العراق
للايرانيين فشفنا دول عربيه كثير قربت على
العراق وصار في تعاون اكثر وصار في الاطار
الثلاث الاطار الذي يمكن التفاهم عليه
مثلا مع هو واحد من اهم ربما
العوامل التي سبقت هذه القمه وبالتاكيد
سيكون ترتيب مساله الاتفاق السعودي
الايراني وعوده العلاقات بين البلديه لكن
تعرف بانه ايران موجوده في اكثر بالعاصمه
عربيه يعني وبالتالي الاطار الذي يمكن
بالفعل لم يتم فيه التواء التفاهم
لمعالجه اشكاليات التواجد الايراني
السابقه اللي موجوده يعني وتاثيراتها كيف
ممكن يتغير الوضع الان صعب لان الايرانيين
بدهم ياخذوا ثمن لكل شيء وبدهم يقرضوك
بدهم يقايضوك على كل قضيه فمش سهل
الايرانيين تقول لهم يلا ينسحبوا من هاي
الملفات ويتركوا لا باليمن له حسابات
بسوريا الهمات بالعراق مش من السهل هذا
النفوذ اللي صنعوه خلال السنوات الماضيه
انه اليوم هذا النفود يعني يتركوه ويتخلوا
عنه بدون اثمان كبيره فتقدير الايرانيين
التعامل معهم راح يكون لكنه زي ما بقولوا
باللغه الفارسيه سيكون بازار بدك تخوض
معهم ببازار طويل ويتقدم لهم دوليا وعربيا
واقليميا مقابل انه يتخلوا عن جزء من
النفود اللي هم صنعوه خلال الفترات
الماضيه واستغلالهم هم نفذوا من الازمات
العربيه دخلوا من خلالها لصناعه نفوذ الهم
اليوم لا يمكن انتخاب رئيس لبناني مثلا
اليوم بدون موافقت ايران لا يمكن الانتخاب
لا يمكن ان الملف السوري انك تروح فيه
خطوات دون ايران العراق لا يمكن بعض الق
الا بمشاركه ايراني اليمن بس هل يمكن في
تفاهم هل هناك مساحه للتحرك لكن بدك تعرف
انه هذا كل شيء له ثمن الايرانيين لا ما
راح يقدموا شيء
مجانا ولا لله تعالى سيقايض على كل شيء
وسيقايض هذه الملفات سيقاض للعالم احيانا
الامريكان من خلال هذه الملفات فمش القصه
سهله لكن الوضع اليوم افضل من السابق في
انك كيف بنحكي حتى اللغه لليوم رح نسمعها
بالخطابات تجاه ايران راح تكون اكثر هدوءا
ما راح يكون زي الخطايا القمامه السابقه
اللي كان فيها هجوم على السياسه الايرانيه
لانه اليوم في مجال لتعامل من نوع اخر مع
الايرانيين وفي خطوات ممكن تكون افضل مع
في التعامل على على تنعكس على الملفات
العربيه اللي موجوده على جلده القمه اللي
هي الايران الايران مشتركه فيها الان
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد رئيس الجمهوريه
السوريه يصل الى مقر انعقاد القمه العربيه
الثانيه والثلاثين
مشهد تاريخي بالتاكيد الان في عمر هذه
المنظومه العربيه بعد قطيع امتدت ل 12
عاما الان الرئيس السوري رئيس الوقتي
السوري اللي يشارك في اعمال هذه القمه بعد
كذلك ان اعلن من قبل جامعه الدول العربيه
عن عوده سوريا لشغل مقعدها في جامعه الدول
العربيه رئيس السوري مقر انعقاد القمه
توجه ايضا
للقاء بو ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد
بن سلمان
في اعلان رسمي الان
لعوده سوريا
لمنظومه جامعه الدول العربيه
نشاهد
دكتور عبد المنعم اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور عبد
المنعم سعيد عضو مجلس الشيوخ المصري
متابعه صور دكتور عبد المنعم
ربما ننطلق من تحدثنا كثيرا عن سوريا
والملف السوري لكن الان بما اننا نشاهد
الان وصول الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد ربما
يعني نتحدث بشكل حول
الاضافه التي يمكن ان تقدم الان لمنظومه
جامعه الدول العربيه بعد عوده سوريا سوريا
كانت احد الاقطاب المهمه في فتره من
الفترات للعمل العربيه
ايضا على مستوى المنطقه على مستوى كذلك
العمل الدولي بشكلنا هو في نتائج عامه
لوجود سوريا والنتائج يعني اقدر اقول انها
خاصه بسوريا النتائج العامه يعني وجود
سوريا في القمه العربيه بسميها انا نهايه
الربيع العربي يعني بنضع قفله على مرحله
سابقه نقدر نقول عليها عقد من الزمان
نتج وبدا كان مشهده الاول الاحداث التي
جرت وخروج سوريا من الجامعه العربيه في
ذلك الوقت انما النقطه اللي هي غير عامه
روسيا سوريا مهمه جدا اولا لعدد من
الملفات الاقليميه هي مهمه للملف اللبناني
هي مهمه للملف الفلسطيني هي ايضا مهمه
للملف الداخلي واثاره في علاقته بالهلال
الخصيب ككل العلاقه مع تركيا فهي يعني
فالمهم
وفاعل الان دخل في اطار المسؤوليه العربيه
يعني طول ما سوريا الموضوع اذا لدي
مسؤوليات تجاه روسيا تجاه تركيا تجاه
اطراف اخرى انما امى والان وقد اصبحت جزءا
من القمه مره اخرى سوف يضاف
لها البعد العربي في هذه
المساله يعني ربما نستشف في حاجه من هذا
المؤتمر عندما يتحدث الرئيس السوري انا
انا هبقى يعني احب اسمائه كيف سوف يصيغ
وضع سوريا داخل المنظومه العربيه على ضوء
كل اللي احنا قلناه يعني
دكتور يعني الى اي مدى يمكن
ان تؤذن الحديث والسياسه التي تمت
والتحركات التي سبقت هذه القمه توحي ربما
تشير الى اننا امام حاله جديده مختلفه يتم
من خلالها العمل وفق استراتيجيه تصفير
المشكلات في المنطقه تهديد حاله التوتر
منطقه في لحظه من اللحظات كانت توشك على
الانفجار كنت تتفق معي في هذا اكثر من ملف
شاهد واكثر من حريق يشتعل في كل الاركان
فجاه شاهدنا حاله من الهدوء بالتالي الى
اي مدى يمكن الب على ما تم من تحضيرات
سابقا خدتها السعوديه الى حد كبير
للبناء عليه في اعمال
القمه في عمل القمه اليوم وخاصه في
اجتماعات القاده المشاركه يعني دائما في
السياسه وفي الاعلام بيبقى في عندنا شوق
اللحظه ميلاد او لحظه موت يعني اللي هي
الاردنيه الملك عبد الله الان يصل فقط الى
مقر انعقد تفضل يعني اللحظات المتطرفه
لحظه الميلاد ولحظه الوفاه انما في
السياسه مش كده السياسه فيها امور
التراكميه
ونقدر نقول ان العشر سنين اللي غابت فيهم
سوريا كانت مرحلتين مرحله استقطاب شديد
والاستقطاب لم يشمل فقط سوريا وبقيه الدول
العربيه وانما داخل الدول العربيه نفسها
التحالف العربي مقابل قطر ومعها ايضا
تركيا من دول الجوار العداء الايراني مع
الحوثيين يعني كان في المنطقه في حاله
هيجان نقدر نقول النص التاني وهقول لنص
التاني او الجزء التاني
بدا مع اعلان العلا اعلان العلا خلق مرحله
داعيه اولا للتهدئه داعيه الى عوده
العلاقات مع قطر ومع تركيا هذه المساله
اخذت من
الفن 2021 الى السنه دي يعني خدت السنتين
كاملتين في عمليه تراكم عماله تتعمل وصلت
للاتفاق الايراني السعودي كنقطه مهمه او
محطه مهمه عوده العلاقات مع مصر وتركيا
عوده العلاقات مع قطر امور كثيره
تطورت خلال هذه المرحله
انا بشوف انه عوده سوريا بيبقى جزء من هذا
الاطار تطبيع العلاقات مع سوريا يعني كان
في محاولات اقتراب مما سمي الشام الجديد
الاردن والعراق
وكان يعني ومصر وكان يعني الحلم ان ياخذ
او يكون جزء منه
اوضه سوريا وايضا التعامل مع الاوضاع في
لبنان
ففي افاق ابتدت جديده تتبني على التراكمات
التي جرت النهارده واحد من نتائجها المهمه
صياغته بقى في الوضع الجديد ده هنسمعه من
الخطاب يمكن ان نستدل منه على ربما ملامح
المرحله او حتى حدود التحرك من من ذلك لان
هو ايضا يعني قادم وسوريا مسخنه بجراح
كثيره مسخنه بجراحه يعني مدمره اقول فعلا
على كل طبعا فيزيكال في ايضا ان عندك
منطقه الشمال الغربي خارج السياده
السوريه لديك ايضا
مشكلات كبيره في التعامل الكردي مع النظام
العام في في سوريا ان سوريا عندها مفاوضات
جاريه تركيا وايران في الاساتانه فيما
يتعلق بالاصلاح الداخلي داخل سوريا هناك
محادثات في جنيف كانت موجوده بين المعارضه
السوريه
والحكومه السوريه في امور كثيره لما تضعها
الدبلوماسي فيها مع العسكري مع الاقتصادي
مع حتى العمراني مع بعضها البعض تلاقي
القضيه السوريه
معقده
وجود الرئيس بشار هو بحثا عن لحظه انفراج
لهذا التعقيم على سلم الاولويات دكتور
سميح تعتقد
اي الملف الذي سيحظى باهتمام اكبر السودان
المشتعله السودان التي اعلنها رئيسها قبل
قليل يعني او قبل ساعه تقريبا اعفاء نائبه
السودان الذي لا احد يتوقع اين يمكن ان
يتجه الصراع
سوريا وعودتها سوريا ملفها الانساني
والاقتصادي واعاده الاعمار والسياسي
وغيرها اليمن عراق اي الملفات سيكون لها
الاولويه والله تشوف الترتيب صعب لكن
تقديري لو انا بدي اكون ضمن الفريق اللي
بصيغ البيان الختامي بشير للقضايا التي
تبعث عن التفاؤل احنا رايحين لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات